Zimmer Kira stehst du eigentlich auf
getunte Autos so richtig Fast and
Furious und so
ich weiß nicht aber es ist schon oft
ganz ehrlich zu sein ja ich muss auch
sagen ich finde es schon ziemlich
faszinierend wie viel Zeit liebe Geld
manche Menschen in ihre Karren so
reinstecken und die Ergebnisse die sind
schon eine irre ja absolut und bewundern
kann man nämlich solche Kunstwerke auf
vier Rädern gerade am Bodensee dort
findet gerade nämlich die größte Tuning
Messe Europas statt und unsere Reporter
Manfred sedlbauer ist für uns vor Ort
wer sonst
[Musik]
die Tuning worlds Bodensee das Mekka für
alle Autofans aufgemotzte kann
quietschende Reifen qualmen Auspuff und
ganz viel nackte Haut doch ist das
wirklich so oder ist das nur eine
Klischee und welche aufgemotzten Autos
sind in diesem Jahr die Hingucker auf
geht's
mehr als
1.500 getunte Wagen mehr als jemals
zuvor sind in diesem Jahr auf der Tuning
World am Bodensee ausgestellt bis zu
80.000 Besucher strömen an den
Messetagen durch die Tuning World sie
alle teilen die Faszination Autor
[Musik]
fallen ist deswegen umso besser jetzt
das wieder stattfinden kann ja schöne
Folierung das für jeden was dabei
Steffi aus Augsburg lebt die Branche
seit Geburt ist der Social Media Star in
der Szene aktiv und hat sich ihren Traum
erfüllt ihr eigenes Auto auf der Messe
auszustellen
ich habe meine Autos meine Barbie Autos
die waren schon getunt die hatten
Chromfelgen und Ledersitze also die
Puppen haben mich nicht interessiert in
Urlaub wenn wir gefahren sind habe ich
die Automarken gezählt und die
auspuffrohrringe mehr desto besser also
vier waren immer schon mein Highlight ja
ich hatte das schon immer irgendwie im
Blut und bin natürlich sehr stolz jetzt
das eigene Auto auch so umbauen zu
können und zu besitzen Jenny und Maria
arbeiten schon seit Jahren auf der
Tuning World kein einfacher Job bei all
den Männern das gehört zu unserem Job ja
wir werden jedes Jahr aufs Neue deswegen
gebucht dass mir natürlich auch irgendwo
der Anziehungspunkt sind ja deswegen
stechen wir auch vielleicht mit dem
Outfit ein bisschen raus ja was wir auch
müssen ist unser Job und schmeichelt
eigentlich gar nicht sondern für uns ist
es einfach wirklich Job ja aber auch
diese Offenheit wir bekommen ja auch das
Feedback mensch ihr seid so offen mit
euch kann man auch mal kurz quatschen
von wem machen sie mehr Fotos von den
Autos oder von den Frauen also von den
Autos gar kein nur von den Frauen ein
kleiner Jägermeister war don't drink and
drive deshalb die Karre lieber stehen
lassen bei Adrian dreht sich alles um
einen Kräuterlikör es war so eine Idee
man hat eine Zapfanlage gekauft dann hat
man die mal ins Auto hinten reingestellt
weil das hat noch keiner und dann ist so
die Idee entstanden und dann
schlussendlich immer mehr umgebaut
[Musik]
ganz nüchtern geht's einen Stand weiter
bei Andre zu dafür kunterbunt
[Musik]
Auto selber hat von VW so geben mit die
Grundfarben da hat VW vier Bonus
hergenommen und nur die die Blechteile
untereinander getauscht aber ich sehe
noch ein bisschen viel grau da muss noch
was getan werden oder ja man hat einen
längeren
und vor allem neuen Autos muss ich sagen
dieser Bulli hier der lässt wirklich
mein Herz höher schlagen
was in diesem Jahr allerdings nicht zu
sehen ist die Wahl zur Miss Tuning ein
Schönheitswettbewerb der seit
Jahrzehnten einfach zur Messe dazu
gehört hat der Grund wiederholte
Sexismusvorwürfe zu sexy für Zeitgeist
absolut überzogen mir ist es egal also
gehört eigentlich dazu ich finde es
eigentlich ein bisschen schade dass es
nicht mehr ist vor allen Dingen könnte
man jetzt auch bei mir aus dem Mist also
Mister Tuning aufstellen also der
Western du also nicht also
was sagen denn die messerexperten dazu
ich
finde es Drogen ja und immer hübsche
Mädels dabei also von dem her ich finde
es mega schade aber jetzt ein Ersatz
durch Mister Tuning finde ich es auch
nicht die Lösung oder das beste Auto
oder sowas Frauen haben auch eine
Daseinsberechtigung in der Tuning-Szene
und ich finde das sollte für die
kommenden Jahre wieder eingeplant werden
auf jeden Fall
von wegen der eigenen Messer und hier
sind nur Ausstellungsstücke hinter mir
auf was weiter geht's richtig ab
[Musik]
ELN qualmen Auspuff quietschen Reifen
und auch etwas nackter Haut auf der
Tuning World Bodensee gibt es eigentlich
nichts was es nicht gibt kein Auto was
es nicht gibt und definitiv eine
triftige Empfehlung für alle Autofans
[Musik]